- [Voiceover] Let's do another example of
using a virtual compass
and virtual straight edge
to draw a tangent line to a circle.
And now we're told to
construct a line going through
P tangent to the circle.
And in this example, P
doesn't sit on this circle,
P is outside of the circle.
So we wanna draw something like,
and actually let me get
my straight edge out.
So my straight edge, and I
have my controls up here,
this is on the Kahn Academy exercise
Constructing a Line Tangent to a Circle,
so I have that up there.
So let me add the straight edge.
Once again, you could try to eyeball it.
We're gonna go through P, going
to be tangent to the circle,
so hey yeah, maybe something like that.
That looks pretty good,
but like we've said
in other geometric constructions videos,
that's just eyeballing it, we don't know
how precise that actually is.
So what if we had a compass
and a straight edge,
how do we make something more precise?
And actually in the process of doing it,
we'll make really fun patterns.
So how do we do that?
Well, what I'm gonna do is,
I'm gonna try to construct a circle
that has the segment PC
as a diameter.
So let me draw that.
So I wanna construct a circle that has
segment PC as a diameter.
And in order to do that, I need to
figure out where the
center of that circle is.
And you'll see in a second
why it's useful to have
this circle that has PC as a diameter.
So where is the center?
It looks like it's roughly here,
but how do we actually construct it?
To do that, we're gonna have to figure out
the midpoint of segment PC, or CP.
And to do that, what I'm gonna do is
construct two circles.
I'll just make 'em a little bit larger.
So one centered at C.
I'll make it reasonably
large, maybe that big.
Then I'm gonna construct another circle
of the same radius
as that large one that I just constructed,
so it's that same radius.
But I'm now going to center it at P.
Now why is this interesting?
Why is what I just did interesting?
Well where these two
larger circles intersect
are going to be equidistant to P and C.
How do we know that?
Well all the points on this
circle are equidistant to C,
all the points on this
circle are equidistant to P,
and these circles have the same radius.
And at this point right over here,
they are equidistant to both of them,
because it sits on both circles.
So this point is
equidistant to both of them,
and so is this point right over here.
And so they both sit on the perpendicular
bisector of this segment.
Of the segment CP.
So actually let me draw that.
So if I draw a line that
looks something like this,
this right over here is
a perpendicular bisector
of line, of segment CP.
Now what we really just care about is that
it is bisecting it, 'cause we wanted
to find the midpoint.
And now that we have found
the midpoint of our segment,
we're ready to construct
that circle I talked about.
A circle centered at the midpoint,
and it has CP as a diameter.
So I got that far, but
why did I go through
all of this trouble to do that?
Well now we're going to use the idea
that if you have a triangle
embedded in a circle
where one side of the
triangle is a diameter,
then you're going to
have a right triangle.
Well what am I talking about?
Let me actually just draw the triangle.
So let me add a straight edge here.
So I'm gonna draw a triangle,
so it has one side as the diameter,
so we're gonna embed it in this circle
that I just constructed,
this circle centered
at this midpoint, this
circle right over here.
CP is clearly our diameter.
And I'm gonna embed it
in CP, but I'm gonna
put it in this point right over here,
'cause this point sits on
the circle centered at C.
And I'm gonna draw another line.
So this other line, let me put
that there, and this there.
So my claim is that this
is a right triangle.
How do I make this claim,
and I've proved it in other videos,
is it's embedded in a circle,
it's embedded in this
circle right over here
that's highlighted in yellow.
It has a diameter for one of its sides,
and that side is actually its hypotenuse.
So and we prove it in other videos.
So this is a right triangle.
Well why is this useful for proving,
or why is this useful for
constructing a tangent line
to this circle over here?
To circle centered at C?
Well, this side right over
here that I have in orange,
that I'm highlighting right now,
that's the radius of C.
And if that forms the right angle
with this line right over here,
then this line right over
here must be tangent.
And to really make it look tangent,
I'll elongate it a little
bit just like that.
And there you go.
You feel good that this looks like
it's truly intersecting at a right angle,
and that this segment
that I'm highlighting
in orange right now, is truly tangent.
So once again, a lot more trouble
than just eyeballing it and trying to
draw it and actually,
a lot of you probably
could have eyeballed this
segment right over here.
But if you're doing
something on a larger scale,
you wanna be more precise,
it's useful to be able
to do these constructions.
And frankly, while you're
in the process here,
while you're dealing with the compass and
the ruler or the straight edge,
you get a new appreciation
for what these tools can do,
and you're also making some pretty
fun patterns and designs.
I almost feel like hanging
this one up on my wall.